the resolution is adopted it was history
in the making the one and only time a
motion to theate was invoked was in
1910 and on that occasion it failed this
time it didn't the office of Speaker of
the House of the United States House of
Representatives is hereby declared
vacant house Democrats joined with eight
Republican hardliners to strip McCarthy
of his position two 116 voted in favor
of removing him 210 voted against it was
a culmination of a bitter and long
standing power struggle between McCarthy
and members of a hard-right republican
faction that had tried to block his path
to the speakership in
January and it was this vote that was
the last straw for the Republican right
the bill is passed and McCarthy
accepting the help of Democrats to pass
a short-term funding bill to avoid a
government shutdown but the seeds were
planted long before in particular an
agreement between President Biden and
the then house speaker on raising the
country's debt limit I think the debt
limit deal was a terrible deal and
that's one of the reason it really was
the original sin of the McCarthy
speakership and it's one of the reasons
I seek to vacate the chair now and after
his victory Gates made clear he'd been
Consulting with former president Donald
Trump I would say that uh my
conversations with the former president
leave me with great confidence that I'm
doing the right thing before the vote
McCarthy had attempted to defend himself
look I I I'm a conservative I'm a
republican I'm a conservative one gets
things done um look I I know we live in
uh our government's design to have
compromise but look we're in the
majority you you don't surrender do you
work with the other side yeah and that's
what I've done North Carolina
Representative Patrick McKenry was
nominated by McCarthy as a speaker
protore or temporary speaker and heal
until a new speaker is
elected but given the divisions within
the Republican party this may not be an
easy process and looming over everything
is the fact that another deadline to
fund the government comes in a matter of
weeks and it's a deadline that a house
in chaos may not be able to meet Mike
Hanah alera
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news news from
Al
jazer